let's say that we want to solve the
inequality x squared plus 3x is greater
than 10 we want to figure out all of the
X's that would satisfy this inequality
well I encourage you to pause this video
now and and I'll give you a hint
try to manipulate it the way that you
would have if this was a quadratic
equation but then as you get to the end
try to reason through it because it's
the the reasoning might departure a
little bit from what you are used to so
I'm assuming you've given a go at it so
the first thing that we might want to do
just to get into a form that we're more
comfortable with is subtract 10 from
both sides if we subtract 10 from both
sides then on the left hand side we're
going to have x squared plus 3x minus 10
is still going to be greater than if we
just if we add or subtract the same
thing to both sides it won't change the
inequality but it's now going to be
greater than 0 10 minus 10 is 0 now this
gets us into a form that we're more used
to seeing quadratic expressions in and
our temptation if this was an equal sign
right over here we'd want to factor this
thing so let's just try to factor it
here too and see what happens so we're
going to factor it we're going to think
of two numbers whose product is negative
10 and whose sum is positive through it
we've had a lot of practice doing this
if you think about the factors of 10
it's 1 2 5 and 10 2 & 5 seem tempting
because their difference is 3 so if you
have positive 5 and negative 2 that
seems to work out positive 5 and
negative 2 their product is negative 10
their sum is positive 3 so we could
write this as we can rewrite this as X X
plus 5 X plus let me do that in that
yellow color so you see where this 5 is
coming from X plus 5 times X minus 2
times X minus 2 is going to be greater
than 0 now this was an equality here we
would say okay well how do we get this
equal 0 one of these two things are
going to be equal to or if either of
these things we're equal to 0 this
entire expression would be equal to 0
because 0
anything is zero we don't have an
equality here we have a greater than
symbol so let's think about how we could
reason through this and I'll do a little
bit of an aside here if I were to tell
you that two numbers a and B and if I
were to take their product a times B and
if someone were to tell you that that
product is greater than zero what do we
know about a and B well we know that
they have to have the same sign they're
either both positive a positive times a
positive is going to be a positive or
they're both going to be negative a
negative times a negative is a positive
is going to be greater than zero so we
know the same thing here so we could let
me write it down so we know we know
either
we know either either a is greater than
zero a is greater than zero and B is
greater than 0 and B is greater than
zero so either both of them are positive
or or both of them are negative or a is
less than zero and B is less than 0 B is
less than zero so we apply that same
logic here you could view this X plus
five is a you could view this X minus
two as our B of the product of two
things the product is greater than zero
that means that either both of these
expressions are positive or they are
both negative so let's write that down
so this tells us that either either I'll
write it this way so either both of
these expressions are positive so either
X plus 5 X plus 5 is greater than 0 and
X minus 2 is greater than 0 and X minus
2 is greater than 0 so either this or or
let me write it this way or X plus 5 or
they're both negative or X plus 5 is
less than 0 and X minus 2 is less than 0
X minus 2 is less than zero so now let's
think about eat all of these
inequalities independently but let's
maintain this logic here of the and and
the or so let's look at this either
they're both positive so if both of
these expressions are positive what do
we know about X well if you subtract 5
from both sides of this inequality you
get X is greater than negative 5 and if
you add 2 to this inequality both sides
of that inequality you're going to get X
is greater than 2 so if X is greater
than negative 5 and X is greater than 2
what do we know about X well any X
that's greater than 2 is going to be
greater than negative 5 so we could just
simplify this right over here to be to
say that X is greater than 2 so all of
this this is equivalent to saying well X
is greater than 2 because clearly
anything that is greater than 2 will
satisfy that and both of these things
have to be true negative 4 for example X
equaling of 4 it would satisfy this
inequality but not this one and so the
and would break down negative 4 does not
satisfy both of these in order to
satisfy both of these you essentially
have to satisfy that one so this
expression simplified to that now what
about this or this what about this
statement right over here well X plus 5
less than 0 subtract 5 from both sides
that is X is less than negative 5 and
add 2 to both sides of that equality you
that inequality you get X is less than 2
now if X is less than negative 5 and X
is less than 2 what do we know about X
well that just means that X has to be
less than negative 5 X has to be less
less than negative 5 if it's less than
negative 5 it's definitely going to be
less than 2 and we got to remind
ourselves that we have this over here
and that's essentially describing the
solution set for this quadratic
inequality here X is going to be greater
than Z X is going to be greater than 2
or X is going to be less than negative 5
and we could actually plot the solution
set on a number line so
this is our number line right over here
and let's say that this is zero this is
let's say that's one two right over here
this is negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 negative 5 that's negative 5
so X could be greater than 2 greater
than 2 not greater than or equal to so
I'm going to put an open circle here so
it could be greater than 2 or it could
be less than negative 5 not less than or
equal to so I'm going to put an open
circle here and so it could be less than
that so X can be either X could be any
number it could be negative 6 negative 6
would satisfy this you can verify that
negative 6 squared is 36 plus 36 plus
negative 18 which is going to be 18
which is greater than 10 or you could
have say a positive 3 would work 3
squared is 9 plus another 9 is going to
be 18 which once again it is greater
than 10